hi friends now you may remember earlier
on this year that I got to go away to LA
and I got to see the guys from Rawat
which was really cool got to record some
routines with them I also got to go and
see the guys from the human garage now
the human garage is a wellness and
movement specialist facility near Santa
Monica just off LA's Beach and I first
heard of them when Ben Greenfield
mentioned them on his podcast they have
a very progressive very forward thinking
and different alternative view of human
anatomy and wellness in general I
thought it would be interesting for me
to pay them a visit so I got in touch
them very kindly they let me go down and
use the facility it ended up being
around about a two to two and a half
hour procedure we were supposed to sit
down and podcast while I was out there
but then the guy who played Superman in
the 2005 movie came in so he he took
precedence but this facility deals with
NBA stars NFL players doctors Hollywood
movie stars they literally have got one
of the hottest spots in all of LA and
very very fortunate to have being able
to go and see them I wanted to get Gary
who is the co-founder on the podcast to
just try and explain where this very
popular very alternative thinking
success has come from and I think he
manages to do it today so I'm not gonna
take it any further I'm going to let
Gary speak for himself one final thing
if you are in LA and you do want to
check out the human garage
they haven't sponsored this episode at
all however the waiting list is
incredibly long if you want to see them
but if you mention modern wisdom when
you book for your consultation
application they will bump you to the
top of the list I'm going to be really
interested
here some feedback about this one so
don't forget get at me actress will ex
on Instagram Twitter wherever it is that
you want to get in touch or modern with
some podcast at gmail.com
but for now on the show
[Music]
Gary welcome to modern wisdom hi Chris
how you doing very good thank you and
yourself I'm doing fantastic sitting
here in Southern California nice and
sunny we've been having a little bit of
a heatwave out here but not too bad in
the UK for one side there actually I'm
gonna guess based on my experience when
I was out with you guys the weather is
not going to be not going to be quite
the same but we'll take we'll take what
we can get in England at the moment for
sure so yeah really good having you out
here it was really interesting I just
wish we had more time with you yeah me
too me too it's um la is one of those
places it's a kind of like a hot spot
for wellness and you know it pushes the
forefront and the boundaries to a degree
of of treatments and of you know I mean
weed is legal out there at the moment
cannabis is legal and you know it seems
like it's um seems like it's very
progressive on all fronts would you say
that's about right yeah I think I think
it's really a progressive in all fronts
I mean I'm from Canada originally and
Vancouver we're a bit more liberal and
in all aspects of things but down here
you've just got a collection of both
athletes professional otherwise Olympic
athletes so you have a little bit more
of the treatment talent and the thought
processes and the modalities that are
out here so you just get a bit more of
everything that's all yeah I get that so
you are the co-founder of the human
garage yes my my wife is my co-founder
she is the boss she signs all the games
I've learned I've learned through
submission to be very next to her
fantastic well you don't want you don't
your paycheck cut that's exactly what
happens with my business partners
sometimes if I piss him off or if I
pissed him off for a little while ill
I'll find out that you've got a bunch of
my paycheck site in the safe for sure
for sure so but we we have a we have a
whole variety of people as you know that
come out here so we have people from all
over the world including UK is our third
largest draw market so we have a quite a
bit of people come from the UK out to
Venice Beach to see us so take everyone
through at home who hasn't heard of the
human courage take us through the story
what why
you started what your ethos is where you
are now and what you do okay fair enough
I mean it's a it's a little bit of a
journey but but one of the best ways for
people to get the the whole story is to
is to listen to some of the backgrounds
I mean there's a number of different
different reports of media outlets that
we've reported to it started from in the
short form the time that we have it
started with me being a professional
bodybuilder back in the 80s and I fell
under a 600-pound squat and from that
point forward the rest of my adult life
I've been in one form of therapy or
another trying to resolve that and I
always using exercise and stretching and
and and chiropractic physical therapy
agha scuba all thing Feldenkrais method
and anything and everything to keep my
body out of pain and it just and I was
always in love like from from my early
20s through to my mid 30s I was in a
tuna phul or pain every day but towards
the end of the my 30s that started being
more like a six to nine pain every day
so after being through every form of
therapy literally known to mankind not
only here but all through Europe all
through Asia and I was just determined
to find a way to solve my issue and I
and I realized that and that if if I
didn't understand enough to tell people
to communicate my issue every time I
went to another modality they had
another way of looking at it so I had to
find a unified way of communicating what
my problems were and so I looked for
four foundations in chiropractic as a
and as physical therapy to try and help
explain my problem so when I don't know
if you've ever experienced this but if
you go from doctor a doctor with a
chronic issue of any kind having to
explain yourself and go through their
process each and every time it gets
pretty tedious and after hundreds and
hundreds of these just start learning
the language so as we learn the language
of chiropractic invisible physical
therapy we went to the next step and I I
was just trying to really solve my issue
SOI I sought out the top ten people and
probably every every industry you can
imagine and went to them wherever they
were in the world
and towards the end as I got into my 30s
my and my back would be going out once
or twice a year but I got to a point
where it was it was starting to go out
every month or two and at the end of it
it was like 10 times I would my back
went out and I would be off about two
weeks at a time and there so I was in in
bed 22 weeks towards the end of my
journey and and that's where the
foundation is where I said something has
to change because you may or may not
experience this or have any relationship
to this but at some point I didn't want
to kill myself but I really didn't want
to be alive anymore it was just a
excruciating pain I can imagine I
imagine it's very very uncomfortable
yeah yeah and they neurologically it
gets stressful too because the pain
itself starts pick up on the paint
well yeah it'll start to repot and
that's correct isn't it especially with
back pain I'm right in thinking that as
you get back pain you'll be you become
more susceptible for further back pain
correct yeah yeah and this because your
your whole body's trying to organize and
keep itself aligned and working in
gravity and that's really what the the
challenge was is that we were looking at
the body the wrong way or in my opinion
the most of the industry has looked at
the body the wrong way and that's part
of the reason why we have so many people
that are in rough shape
okay so that's the the setup I suppose
who was it that you went to go and see
you said that you went to go and see a
number of experts around the world can
you remember who they were yeah I just
don't feel it appropriate to call it
people but nothing worked
so if I had a smashing success with
somebody and may even want to call it
out but this just basically and it
wasn't the practitioners it's just the
way that we there we were approaching
the body each modality learned how to
help the body with its background and
its own view of the body and if you
don't fit any one of those boxes and you
know there's a number of people out
there that are going around for the
practitioner practitioner and for
modality the modality and it's just and
they they trade off a little bit of
success or a little bit of pain
reduction but but then they have to go
somewhere else and that's typically what
happens people just get pushed around
from therapy to therapy until until one
time that there
just no longer to do it able to do it
anymore and that's that's that's
generally what happens to people today
yeah yeah I can understand that so why
do you go from there you've spent enough
time with the doctors that you feel like
you could do their job for them and what
yeah what comes after that
well you know hey there's number of
different things so I was using a
whatever therapy I could to manage my
own pain and discomfort and people
always asked what kind of pain was it
was back pain neck pain
it was generalized discomfort it was it
was something where I would have ribs
going on all the time my neck would go a
long time and there just seemed to be no
ax no solution for it so at one point
all the places I travel in the world and
I am literally meeting all through
Europe and all through Asia one of the
places that I found a guy in Orange
County which is about 45 minutes south
of where I am right now and he had a
neuromuscular therapy that he was using
to make Olympic runners run faster and
that therapy got me up and over the
hurdle and and as long as I did it twice
a week I was virtually out of pain now I
still have high levels of discomfort but
you know when you've been in pain for a
long time day or two without pain is
just you'll take anyone you can get the
next ones right yeah and that therapy
was got me out of pain I used that we
had the time it's called brain body
calibration it I looked at the guy who
was doing the therapy he was a PhD and
medical science kinesiology and pain
management and I looked at him and said
he's about ten years older than me he's
probably gonna die before me I don't
mean that to be facetious but I'm
looking at saying this is the only
therapy I've had in 20 years that keeps
me even stable I'm gonna need somebody
else to do this so I convinced him to to
go off and higher we started up the
Rubenstein centers and we hired five
doctors forty therapists their boats and
we used that as a as a platform to start
and expand his thought process which was
a neuromuscular therapy and like I said
therapy got me out of pain but I had to
do it twice a week and I became a victim
of yet another problem which was the
fear of pain so I was out of pain I had
to go on a vacation
and I knew that it within the two weeks
that I was going to be gone that I would
be in pain before I got back and I and I
just couldn't get myself to leave
because I couldn't get myself to go into
that level of pain again and that's
where I realized that that my solution
was was to manage my pain through
treatment wasn't a good solution I
needed to find an answer and so as we
look to additional modalities to try and
bring them in to help me understand what
to do next my partner at the time just
you know he said it was my name on the
door and it was and his Rubenstein
centers and he said so no this is a
modality of staying here so at that
point I decided to to leave and and
continue my journey and find a way to
get myself permanently out of pain and
that's what led to the human garage Wow
so what was it specifically that you
think was the difference between the
most recent treatment that we've just
been discussing there and everything
that you'd tried previously because as
you say it didn't necessarily fix the
discomfort but it did fix the pain and
that's a pretty big step to take at the
beginning so can you identify what it
was about that treatment that was
different
yes treatment we were using previous to
this if you look at it I mean people
have seen it online you see two or three
people standing around a table it kind
of looks like a RT but the intention was
much different we had a fun basically
there's been two fundamental beliefs
that have been with us since the day we
started the first one was the human body
is designed to heal itself and if it is
designed to heal itself we either have
to stimulate it into doing something or
or stimulated into not doing something
and just let the body figure itself out
that's that's the one primary belief
that we had in the second one was I just
I didn't believe that I was unfixable I
didn't believe that I was the only one
that everybody I knew that had to
continue doing therapy for the rest of
my life so with that foundation of
belief where I literally started working
in a garage it was my garage here in
Venice Beach and I had had a PT that I
was working with and we were just
experimenting
and we're just following a series of
what seemed at the time dumb ideas or
just illogical ideas and we had a series
of discoveries which led to led to how
the body was managing itself in gravity
basically and when we figured that out
all of a sudden we we'd done a very
specific release on one of the letters
in my right leg and I stood up straight
for the first time in my life without
any tension it was very bizarre
experience but but that's what let us
believe that there's this more to this
and what we learn in school there's more
to this and what we've been educated
about and it's sort of opening up this
process of always looking for a better
way and always investigating ok so did
you do during this period when you were
developing the human courage did you do
any formal training did you go into
physiotherapy education did you do any
biomechanical work or anything like that
or was it kind of learn as you go well
it depends what you consider be formal
training yeah I've spent 25 years
studying educating hiring people to
train me paying for training going for
courses and seminars I mean heck I
started a business with a PhD in medical
science and had five doctors and dozens
of therapists defending his science so
yes there's a lot of Education but the
formalized education and most people can
relate to this you go to school you
learn a bunch of stuff then you go off
and you go into your practice or into
your career and you use almost nothing
that you learn in school I know it's not
really no different in health care a lot
of the education comes from being out
there working with people and seeing
live results yeah that's yeah that's
that's totally correct I guess the
letters the letters in front or behind
your name are just they're really just a
fail-safe for someone who doesn't know
you that says I have the minimum
required education that someone should
do to be able to practice what you think
that you want from me yeah I'm the I'm
the least trained or educated person
here I'd say I'm serious I mean I have I
have actually technically outside of
nutrition training and supplement
training and you know I'm taking courses
on biomechanics and fashion and stuff
like that but those are more
more interest courses that you would
take as a practitioner but for the most
part yeah my training came from the
street but that what what that allowed
me to do is ask a lot of dumb questions
Chris and you know when you ask them
questions you get smart answers and you
know like for example let's just this is
jump off the deep end where do we start
off with I I looked at it and said okay
I have a problem and my background just
so you know is when I got out of school
in the 80s you could go and be a doctor
for $150,000 a year you could go and be
a lawyer for about $200,000 a year or
you could go into wireless industry and
technology and make three-quarters of a
million dollars a year so I did what any
young man would do went into wireless
yeah the technology and I went I went
where the money was and and I but as I
started getting more and more problems
as sick are more and more dysfunctional
I started organizing more of my life
around my dysfunction so in other words
if I'm going to a telecom conference in
Miami and I had a choice between Miami
and California I think the one that had
a health conference somewhere around
that time and I started double-dipping
in my in my travel because I was really
trying to figure out you know what the
issue we know what the issue was the
nice thing about asking stupid questions
is I get it as I said let's talk dive
off the deep end I gotta ask the biggest
one which is is the brain in charge of
the body and you know fundamentally
scientifically that's not true it's a
command center but it's not the command
center and if it was a command center
Chris and why is it then when a baby is
being developed with the heartbeats
before the brain is lost that's
interesting so what do you mean about
the brain not being in control what's
not in charge it's a control center yeah
so it's not if you think of your body
like we've we've context a lot and
contextualize this experience of being
human and we try to make analogies so we
feel grounded in those analogies like we
say our brain is like a computer well
let me give you another reference point
how about your body's like a computer
and your brain is like a CPU it runs
programs the brain is always analyzing
the internal an extra
environments and posed upon us and
adapting us to the environments and you
know the latest research on the vagal
nerve shows that 90 percent of the
information goes up the vagal nerve to
the brain again that's another indicator
that maybe the brain isn't in charge and
so if so the world of science and
medicine starts to split right there
either I either the brain is in charge
of the body or the brain is just another
organ that's part of the body's
operation and if you say the brains in
charge of the body then the body is a
meat suit and then that's that's where
traditional medicine and thought
processes go down but there's this whole
new world of people that are saying hey
there's way more to this than we think
it's like for example your fashio which
we're working on when you were here
Chris yep is a hundred trillion cells
your brain is a hundred billion cells
that's a thousand times that's a
thousand stomachs in your head or sorry
in your fashio your your brain is your
fashion as a thousand times more
organically dense than and it's
supposedly the command center in the
body and if you think about the faster
from the inside of your skull so the
inside of your feet right on your toes
it's a complete sheet of material
connective material and I'll give you a
way to reference it think about that
material it's all one big sheet and in
there there's pockets and then those in
those pockets lights muscles tendons and
bones and organs so basically if you
think about it that way that's more of a
true representation of the body and the
body has all these input systems or
these intelligent systems that have to
work together and they're interdependent
and each one is dependent upon the other
ones like even the brain it's dependent
upon your senses to give you information
so one of the things we get here with a
lot of people is they'll have a
neurological like a vestibular in your
ear balance issue and their brain
perceives that they're falling over well
if you have a vestibular issue and
you're trying to do body work or
chiropractic work or alignment work or
train yourself or get your gluts afire
it's not going to fire because
neurologically the brain has the wrong
information and the body acts
accordingly so the idea is is that we
can't separate mechanics from neurology
from organ function
this were all has to be looked at
together and the problem with our
current system evaluation and treatment
is they're all broken apart okay I
understand I understand I've Maya is
self myofascial release to one degree or
another is like a mainstay of almost all
strength sports are almost all sports in
in general pretty much every from casual
to professional sports person's gonna
have a foam roller or lacrosse ball or
whatever in there in their kit bag right
so sure to one degree people are aware
that the fash is important but it sounds
like you're putting a lot more emphasis
on it then preemies previously had been
is that right yeah yeah I mean there's
there's a there's a lot of stuff I mean
we don't have the time on this podcast
to dig into it and if people want to
listen this there's a lot more where
where I I've gone into this into deeper
fashions but basically you think about
it this way the the fascia is completely
wraps the body it's super intelligent it
information travels beyond the speed
light faster than you can feel it like
if you were to if you're sit there right
now and you're clenching your right jaw
you'll feel in your right foot the
second you clinch your right jaw if the
problem is is that a nerve signal takes
about a second I have to make that same
distance transit and so if you really
look at it is the way that we're getting
information that our brain and body
operates on is it really what we're told
them the answer scientifically is coming
up no one no no so you everywhere you
think that it's something to do with the
fashion that's communicating is that
right like the fuch is communicating
signals it does there's no question
about it
it takes a second and a half for a nerve
signal from the foot to the brain back
to the foot again so when you walk off a
curb and you hit a sharp rock how can
you move so fast you know in medicine we
say it's in science we say oh it's a
reflex
like the ganglion reflex but that's an
in that san unintelligent movement if I
hit my knee a doctor hits my knee with a
hammer my knee is gonna jolt right yeah
but if I step off a curb and I have zero
drop shoes and I step on a rock and I
jump and I move intelligence that's not
the same response as
dr. hitting my name of the hammer so the
question is a nerve signal cannot travel
to the brain that fast so how is that
signal getting here yeah good question
good question well so our hypothesis is
it's fashion we deliver it every day by
we know we can see we can demo it in
just 10 seconds while you're sitting on
a table but the whole point is let's
just say this without getting into the
particulars and having catfights about
what is and what isn't let's just say
that the information that we have
doesn't adequately explain the
experiences that we are currently living
in and if that's the case then we that
that just opens a door to us to look in
investigating the human garages we
recognize that there's a truth in every
single modality that's out there and you
know that we have MDS we have
chiropractors we have nutritionists we
have naturopathic doctors we've got
bodywork we got pts and neurologically
train trainers we've got every form or
every discipline that helps your human
body into one location you were very
well very well armed with different
practitioners while I was there there
was about I think maybe six people
upstairs all of whom were from a
different background or a different
discipline and then at wandering I think
about four or four of them were working
on me yeah yeah exactly and and that's
the other part too is that the body you
know we can get into that too but the
body just it it it's not the way that we
think it is and again if we open up that
question and that thought process you
start to you start to investigate and
look at more so part of the reasons why
there's four people working on you is
that there's three distinct regions of
the body the lumbar the thoracic and the
cervical and each of those regions
habits has its own little eco structures
things that it does that's important
like like pressure relief valve your
head has a pressure relief valve in
series your lumbar has a pressure relief
valve that's your yeah your your
backside and your diaphragm itself at
the top the diaphragm has two pressure
relief valves one with the esophagus and
one with the arteries and and the body
is always trying to balance the pressure
and the mechanics and what you
experience when you're there there's
three of us working on you you're
standing up
and there's three people touching you in
different areas your body and what we're
doing is stimulating a response and
we're asking your body to figure itself
out yeah just as a brief segue here if
anyone is listening on itunes you're
gonna have to imagine this or Spotify
wherever you're tuning in however if you
are on YouTube I'll make sure the video
guy Dean overlays all of the footage all
of the imagery that I got while I was
having this treatment inhuman garage so
head to maan and wisdom on YouTube to
checked out if you want to see just what
Gary's actually talking about here well
it does it does look a little bit like
if it's a still image it looks a little
bit like an army of people and maybe
fighting me but if you see if you see a
video it's a number of people twisting
right there's a twisting motion going on
yeah yeah and what we're and what we're
doing is we're providing facial inputs
to different regions of the body and the
reason why we do this this is actually
the interesting thing kress is yeah
because people that have no reference to
us they're like why are you doing
therapy standing up and I'm like well
it's pretty simple in my mind we're
meant to be standing and walking in
gravity so if I want my body to act in a
certain way the best thing to do is put
it in a natural environment let it
figure itself out I looked at the human
body and said this you know again asking
dumb questions
I looked at and said okay if I'm gonna
fix myself I'm gonna approach it like a
tech problem like I did everything else
and I said what are what's my goal I
want I have a back pain neck pain is
bloating I have brain fog I have I have
pain in my feet I want to be able to
stand and walk without pain and
dysfunction and at that point that's all
I'm saying I mean I'm at the point now
where I'm gonna play sports again for
the first time in two decades which is
not smoking I'm gonna choose to play I
don't know well you know I've been
trying to make a decision which I go
back to but I have such a fan of golf
but I want to do something team-based so
maybe it's some point you've got built
having been around you for a little
while you've got the build for someone a
little bit bigger than a golfer I know
it's just that little white ball it's
such a pesky thing you know it's like
all I wanted to do is get in the hole
and all it does is fight me yeah
yeah I felt that
before as well so so the strongest
action I looked at and said okay what is
it what are the things that are imposed
on on the body and literally I wrote
down like this gravity atmospheric
pressure
emotional stress sleep deprivation
dehydration I went through it and missed
all the things that were potentially
wrong in my body or that were wrong and
only to find out that the first two had
never been thought about than 3,500
years we've never considered our body's
ability to adapt to contact to
compensate around atmospheric pressure
and gravity and since those are the two
factors that are that the single-largest
imposing factors on human condition as
atmospheric pressure and gravity and in
3,500 years we've never considered that
at any form of therapy mechanics sports
mechanics and any way shape or form that
just doesn't seem logical to me and so
when we when we looked at that we
started with what happens when we put
the body in gravity and what we found
out as you saw Chris is a very unique
thing happens the body strongest of the
strongest action of a human existence is
our ability to adapt or compensate and
we're great at compensating now the
thing is we put the body and gravity and
we give it inputs the body has to adapt
to our inputs and gravity and the
adaptation is a unification between the
three areas of the body and once that
happens everything else starts to just
work better okay yeah I mean I remember
when we sat down I remember you
discussing the spiral of gravity going
down and how that can affect affect
different areas of the body I remember
you speaking about the atmospheric
pressure as well so how do how do
natural forces like pressure air
pressure and gravity how do they own
Prime the body or how do they prime the
body for injury should I say how do they
own prime it for being optimal right
okay so yeah I'm trying to decide how
far we go into these discussion as far
as you want Gary yeah which we do have a
time restriction though you get about 30
minutes left right so yeah so the
so basically imagine this your honor if
you've never held a gyroscope I
encourage people this hold one for once
because you put a little gyroscope
besides your palm in your hand and you
hold in your arms straight out and your
whole body will want to turn around it's
bizarre but basically we live on the
planet Earth Earth spends it a thought
house miles an hour and that creates a
centrifugal or spin gravity and it
travels at 66,000 miles an hour around
the Sun so it's another gravitational
force and what we're doing is we're
standing against it and gravity's not
just pulling us down it actually pulls
us and slightly torques us and depending
on our orientation and where we are
Emma spheres northern hemisphere
southern hemisphere there's a slight
difference at the equator there's a
difference because gravity is imposing a
different force on us and those
behaviors and those in those areas so
when we're in the northern hemisphere
and we're being pulled down are you
typically you're gonna have a little bit
of a pull from your left shoulder to
your right yep so you're pulling and
rotating into your right a little bit
and that's why most people that's why
the most common injuries 80% of people
they tend to have injuries in the same
generalized areas and that's because we
have the same basic forces applied upon
us so 80% of people in the northern
hemisphere have got an injury which is
left shoulder or right hip is that
correct
no they got a tension pattern in left
shoulder to right here okay usually yeah
so we have a joke here at the garage we
say that murderers are silent but
victims scream and what I mean by that
is is that the tight muscle is the
murderer you don't feel it
silent but what you feel is all the
muscles reacting to it all the screaming
from all the muscles that are trying to
resolve that one issue the one muscle
named tight that's the referred pain so
to speak right yeah we referred pain a
reaction to so so typically people are
tighter on one side most people can tell
you I'm tighter and my right side you're
my left side and most people are tighter
on one side of their body and the
injuries typically happen on the other
side because the body's comp sitting
around it but what I am saying is is
that 80% of people have the same basic
tension pattern because we do things
basically the same way and we we tend to
throw the ball most of the time with it
right hand right with our right hand now
there's
Lefty's - and there's people that are
back and forth goofy or ambidextrous but
just generally the majority of the world
has it has the same type of issues so if
the same forces are implied upon the
body then there comes into things like
socialization do I play a sport do I
walk do I sit down and all those things
just start to change and but after a
while you start to Northern Pass known
as patterns in the physical medicine
industry most practitioners would see
but they have about 25 or 35
appointments a week 35 is on the top
side usually and you're gonna see people
usually once or twice a week twice a
week it's kind of a norm when you're in
a repair status and so you're talking
about somebody having somewhere between
12 and 18 clients a week they see and
they're gonna double it up over the
course of the month and they're gonna
see them a couple times in a month so
they're most likely seen above 50 to 60
people a month in the human garage and
you know our formats open we you know
we're into the two and a half to three
thousand appointments a month so we have
such a broader aspect to see things and
since it's an open format I'm not only
witnesses what's happening on my table
I'm working on you Chris or while we're
working in a corner I can see all the
other people working what's going on so
my my scope of what what is normal or
what patterns are starts - starts to
really enlarge I guess your your sample
that you're taking data from in whatever
form you want to say that is wider by by
a pretty big factor if you guys if you
guys are moving through between two to
three thousand clients a month and as
you said at the beginning and this is
something that I did want to emphasize
for people that are listening at home
the range of the range of clients that I
saw while I was in there I think you had
a pregnant woman followed by me then
followed by the guy who played Superman
in the 2005 movie is that right yeah
brand-new Ralphy yeah run Brandon rouse
is it well yeah yeah so yeah and you've
got an affair
yeah all sitting there on the same
tables right beside each other going
through the same therapy you know my
general thing is if it works it works
and it shouldn't be less because you
have less money ours are we're
neutralizing therapy costs so people pay
the same price for the same work that
gets done on a professional athlete gets
done on a pregnant lady I mean we maybe
do different therapies but yeah you
might not quite have the same
physiological demands but it's nice it's
certainly nice for people to be able to
feel like they get to the same level of
treatment I certainly know from personal
experience that if you go into some
physiotherapy studios you know if you've
kind of been put in with the apprentice
or the master sometimes sure and
especially when your health on the line
or an injuries on the line and you want
to feel like you're getting the best
service that's not a it's not a very
conducive environment so definitely
don't say anything right yeah that's and
that's an interesting dilemma Chris
because then you know the world of
health care we what we do is we we we
put the practitioner the guy who has a
therapy on pedestal and you'll see that
even if you go through our media and
stuff like that you'll see podcasts from
all my practitioners doctors and stuff
like that because this isn't about me
first of all and second of all is that
it's not a very good strategy to have
the to have the the access to help
people a limited resource so I am a
limited resource there's only one of me
and but the idea is to be able to take
and have a system that allows my that
allows my staff whether they've been
here two months or three months or six
months or 12 months or a year or five
years to be able to deliver the same
give the same end result and the same
end result is and we found a way of
systematically doing it so you know the
junior practitioners as I was gonna say
you've been able to expedite your
training is that right yeah yeah it's a
lot of hands-on the junior practitioners
are the hands for the senior
practitioners and our practitioners are
called motion mechanics and torque
mechanics
so what happens is you start off as an
assistant and depending on your level
skill your ability to understand you
move to become a torque mechanic and
then the senior the most advanced part
ISM as a massive motion mechanic and
then a master motion mechanic and the
the difference really is is that we
encourage our practitioners to be
multi-disciplined like for example a
master motion mechanic makes more money
than a motion mechanic but the reason
why is because they understand a
neurological rehabilitation they
understand the chemistry and the
supplementation aspect they understand
the fascial work they understand the
chiropractic portion so they have a
wider range of knowledge and but at the
end of the day really all you care about
is as a client is that you come in the
pain that you have or the issue have is
looked at understood addressed and
results and that's what we've been good
at and and it's it's not the Gary line
am Joel for sure and I'm trying to make
myself less and less and less available
well I mean that's how from a business
perspective that's how you make yourself
how you make the business bigger than
you right and obviously that's how you
ski you allow yourself to scale as well
yeah I think what you've touched on the
the must be you must here some skeptical
voices in the industry both from people
who are established and defensive from
people who don't understand or aren't
willing to understand but I think what
you focused on is correct if someone
comes in and they have a pain or they
have a discomfort they have a problem
and when they leave or at the end of
their course of treatment or whatever is
if that has been reduced then the method
has been effective and correct do you
think in the industry not everybody buys
into that though you know like I'll give
you a really I'll give you an example 25
percent of our clients are doctors
medical practitioners chiropractors
physical therapists surgeons whatever
and I was dealing with a guy not too
long ago he'd been in pain for about 15
years and within 45 minutes he's out of
pain literally out of pain for the first
time in 15 years and and I said you know
he was in
somebody else got to come in bottom
initial consultation it was he would
kind of pushed him into going and and
and he's he's an orthopedic by the way
and and at the end of it I I just said
hey how do you feel interesting enough a
lot of pain and I said well let's let's
go forward unless let's take this to the
next step and let's work this out so
that you can have this as permanent
solution you know something that you
know what imagine cuz you know science
hasn't worked out on this so I you know
I'm thinking wait a little while to see
to see how this all shapes up and I'm
like you got to be kidding you've been
in pain for 15 years you're now out of
paying for the first time in 15 years
and you want to wait and talk to
somebody about it you know it's that's I
mean that's that's kind of that's a
perfect example for what I was referring
to there which is potentially people
dogmatically sticking to whatever their
ideology is whatever their school of
thought is and not not permitting
themselves to allow the effect of
whatever the treatment is to move
through them so I mean why is ID Chris
that's a society thing so we we value in
our society time and linage more than we
value results but that's a lovely a
lovely little synopsis no you were
taught you're absolutely right
I mean it does it feel sometimes like
you guys at the human garage because you
are quite progressive you know there's a
bed of crystals 4d charging which I want
to get onto in a second and does the
talk therapy and three practitioners
working at once do you sometimes feel
like that may be an easy target for kind
of vindictive critics and stuff like
that to go on no I I don't I guess it
could be I don't know if it hasn't been
so far and I'll tell you why is because
publicly we've never told people how we
do if we do we just do it so the one
thing it's hard to argue with you can't
argue with results you want you also
can't argue against a process that you
don't know what it is either I suppose
correct yeah you can't pick it apart so
and by the way that's purpose yeah at
first personally like how do you do you
really care how I did it do or do you
just really want to know that it's been
done because you know I can spend all
this time draw
the technical aspects and talking about
the science of it and back and forth and
our investigation how we found it or or
just just want it done and that's so the
idea is that it kind of splits into two
categories the people who just really
want to get it done initially and then
then the ones that that you know that
have to understand and if they want to
understand they come in here will
explain we explain to people as they
come through the process we explain
everything that we're doing why we're
doing it
we show them the thought process even if
they have some mystery like their body
work or a chiropractor this is how you
would look at it before correct this is
how we look at it this is what we're
gonna do and we're always there to
explain to people but just generally as
a rule of thumb I think that the more we
try to explain right now the more the
less credible it sounds I mean listen I
was just working and just before I got I
got on this podcast with you I had a guy
that had been working with and he was an
old client he's been you know probably
four and a half years ago five years ago
really when we were starting the thought
process right and so he hadn't has been
been here in about four years somewhere
in that range he comes back in and Nan
the ain't looking at him it would have
been okay we're gonna be here for the
next 12 hours of therapy six sessions or
seven sessions eight sessions and in 35
minutes he walked out better than he had
ever walked out of the human garage and
and that was that's a that's a shift
because even for a practitioner who's
used to delivering a result but but they
know what to kind of time and energy
takes to deliver the results to be in a
situation where you know 20-30 minutes
they can do more and they used to do an
age of ten hours that's a little hard
for people as well and by the way that's
our biggest problem with practitioners
today is training them is that it just
looks too simple they can't let go of
the tether to their previous education
to to one degree or another oh yeah and
this has got to be the worst industry in
the world where people are tethered to
education I've ever seen well it's it's
interesting so as I was learning about a
theory called working from first
principles it's something which Elon
Musk does a lot and it definitely sounds
to me like y'all for one of a better
time you
lack of education formal education
within the industry has permitted you to
look at these issues in a new light and
yeah you know if you're if you guys are
doing between 2,000 and 3,000 clients a
month and of those about it's actually
appointment they're sorry sorry about
that but that would mean that'll mean
sort of
circa what 100 to 200 healthcare
professionals if about 25 percent of
them are from the healthcare industry if
you've seen people once a week or twice
a week something like that you know it's
a it's a good number of health care
professionals are coming through the
door
probably about 750 since we started Wow
something that's that's a significant
number of people with you know I mean
what's that 750 you do about five years
in medical school for each of those
people so you talking on like nearly
4,000 years of study and absolutely and
these people are coming back for one
reason or another they are coming back
yeah usually usually starts off as
you're skeptical or not come in here
with an issue solve the issue then they
usually trial it with a few absorptions
something like that and it works out and
just start referring and that's why we
didn't have a website to last year and
we weren't open to the public
we'd have a website until the last year
yeah it there's no point in like you've
I mean we have a we have a reputation
people are trying to get here there's no
point in knowing people even even
further thing if the waiting list is
like eight months or a year like we had
people last year that we're calling them
up or cycling through I did podcast with
Ben Greenfield last year and there was
there was a couple people that was about
150 people that still hadn't had some
sort of contact with us and we're
contacting them they're like oh yeah I
forgot that I'm on that waitlist and
we're and by the way we're way better
now because we've increased our capacity
but it's been an on it's been a growing
process like a year ago there was only
six people total that did therapy today
there's five people doing therapy us how
many was that sorry six last year and
there's about twenty five this year okay
and I guess as you've said expediting
the training from being previously how
long was it you know is nine to twelve
months to have somebody functional and
you know realistically you know 12 to 18
months they have to be comfortable with
I could walk away today that that's 35
or 80% reduced because it's just that
the tenants of what we do I wish we had
more time to talk about how torque
affects the body but that is the magic
of what we do the untaught cannot was
you know that was the buzzword if I was
to take a word away from the session
that we'd had it would have been on
talking and you know the the spiral down
there's a cool YouTube video that I will
make sure that Dean overlays in YouTube
and I will put in the show notes below
where a guy pops a flower in a funnel
and he's next to the equator have you
seen this yes yeah yeah pops it in on
one side and it spins one way and he
pops it in on the other side and it
spins the other way and then he walks to
this line on the floor and puts it on it
and pops the water in and it falls
straight down our bodies here I'm not
sure what percentage water but I know
that it's a lot 75 75 percent water
there we go thank you that's why I've
got you here Gary you just an assistant
to it to deliver me facts about water
and and you know it does it sound
ridiculous that our bodies would be
subject to that as well I mean we're not
constantly draining but you know I think
thing blood this way I say this all the
time to people we're 75% water so what
basically we're an aquarium with legs
yeah and if you start you know I like to
take these wild extreme comparisons to
either show how right or how wrong
things are so basically every law that
governs water on the planet Earth
governs the entire inside of your body
and the fact that we think that physics
and engineering and and natural laws of
nature that that that we should be
different is the problem I mean we just
any human being we're on the top of the
food chain we're the best in the
universe we've you know grew up thinking
we're alone and no one else in this
whole 14 point
donar universe that goes hundreds of
billions of light-years no one else
could be alive I mean it's just think
about how ignorant we are when we say
stuff like well honor to segue on that I
recently did a podcast with Adam Frank
who wrote a book and recently did
published a paper on exactly that what
the likelihood is of us being alone in
the universe actually if you just want
to go to just go to NASA's website and
you'll see it all leaking out with UCLA
they just did a report and they said no
actually even in our own solar system
there are thousands of planets in our
solar system that have to have lights I
mean they're really reversing the
thought process it's just it's just when
you've stuck to a parting line for you
know for like a hundred years and then
you find new evidence you don't want to
attack tackle it so quick because if you
mean in our galaxy or no solar system no
and it's re in our solar system in our
galaxy they're just saying life is
everywhere and this is all new stuff
nASA has been releasing over the last
twenty four months and it's not big
press releases you just look because
they're required to release so they
actually the the UCLA NASA report just
said that the entire universe is teeming
with life okay well I mean and that's a
diversion we're with Adam Frank we'll be
we'll be very happy to hear that so I
want to I want to cover two more topics
before we before we certainly show so
first off I want to talk about how you
think that strength and conditioning
complement what you're doing or how they
fit into what it is that you guys are
doing we've discussed the falcon at the
body the body Repat ins movement and
moves itself around pain to me it would
feel if someone's had pain for an awful
long time and has reprogrammed bad
movement patterns it seems difficult to
believe that they would be able to be
Repat and in the space of one hour does
that make sense yeah fair enough so
there's there's a there's structural so
the balances the energy that my body
uses the stand against gravity and then
there's movement movement is where those
patterns come in and if you don't
rehabilitation or movement afterwards
then the we are basically
bodies are a collection of everything
that we have done to date
whether it's movement whether its food
whether it's drugs whether it's
psychological emotional issues our body
is the scoreboard for everything and and
if you could think maybe we could do one
thing for the listeners yes you could
take and put your hands out on your
knees so your thumbs are on the inside
so if thumbs are on the inside and I'm
doing it no I'm doing it no okay so turn
from your thumb on your one side you
might need to turn your thumb towards
your little finger so you're turning
away from the sin of your body
mm-hm and initially and within seconds
you're gonna feel your arch tighten up
you're gonna feel your quad your
lateralis tighten up your glute tighten
up and all the way up into the back do
you get any of that Chris I think well
I've got sweaty hands at the moment but
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so so basically
what that is is applying a little bit of
lateral torque in the knee and then all
these muscles to lateralis the ghast
rocks the medial arch my performace all
tighten up immediately if you turn it
the other way so that the little fingers
are coming to the thumbs and you hold
that within seconds your back will
release your quads will release your
legs will release and that's that's a
sudden example by the way that we have a
home care program we're gonna be out in
about two months we're partnering with
Gwyneth Paltrow we're putting you out to
the world for free you're partnering
with winneth Paltrow for a home care
program yeah that is a really really big
name to have behind a home Capra I mean
it's not one that I would have
immediately I guess going is Gwyneth
Paltrow into a wellness and and stuff
yeah she's a platform out here called
goop G oo p okay what's on ask for the
names well so what does goop do there
it's a health and wellness platform but
it's for people that are moving towards
health and wellness it's not the same
kind of people that we're talking about
we're into fitness nutrition who can
read repeat to you what they're you know
why they're taking a microbiome test and
stuff like this these are more it says a
broader base of people yeah but it has a
big reach it has you know roughly about
50 million
on the reach and so what we're doing is
a home care program which is in 15 to 20
minutes you can reduce your own tension
and pain your body by up to up to 75
percent the reason why we're doing that
the reason I did that with your knees
that's one of the home care activities
and the reason why we we're releasing
this in this way is that part of the
time that we're rolling out and
stretching tight muscles well then it's
really just the torque in a joint and if
we remove the torque out of the joint
the muscles automatically relax
I'll send it over to you Chris oh but
I'll send a I was working with for those
you guys football fans but different
football here we have American Football
we have the Philadelphia Eagles in
Haloti Ngata he's a 345 pound back ER
and you know he's been there league for
16 years I think he you know he's one of
those guys who walks really slow from
the car to the place he doesn't move
that fast right linebacker he's 345
pounds I'm surprised he can get out of
the car he's a big boy big boy yeah so
we did the torque work on him and
without any warm-up he just ran he ran
the 40 he ran it eight times he ran it
as fast as when as the day he qualified
in the lake and we did no other form of
therapy to him we just removed what was
stopping him from performing so my my
basic belief is this is that the body
and the muscles are designed to do a job
and the job that they're designed to do
if you remove the restrictions it'll do
it and so we spend all this time trying
to get like my glute to fire harder or
whatever remove the torque from the
muscles and the body will perform
accordingly so this goes back to your
one of the first principles that you
mentioned which is that you believe that
the body the body knows what it wants to
do in the body is able to fix itself but
sometimes there's inhibitions and these
roadblocks that get in the way and those
are those are manifesting themselves in
the fasciae most in the joints in the
fashion in the joints in the fuch are in
the joints mostly and the one of the
remedies to that is on talking yeah and
if you and torque the muscles then you
get to see what really happening because
like it's like when we did the knee you
felt you felt a couple muscles starting
to tighten up well if you hold that
there for
thirty minutes you're gonna want to
you're gonna want to take a ruler roll
out that muscle but if you just have to
turn the knee and provide a counter
torque and that all was way by itself
then the rolling of the muscle was
actually an ill effective action it was
actually creating damage to the body or
attention the body didn't need to have
and that's part of the best part of the
issue so like what we've done with our
athletes is the they stretch between 75
and 90 percent less once their bodies in
torque and they have a basic on torquing
pattern for themselves and and little
things like this is like like running
pro athletes without warming up I'm not
suggesting you do that but yeah but but
I you know knowing what we're doing I'm
taking a pro athlete who doesn't run and
he's running as fast as than in 16 years
just by taking the torque of the joints
I mean it sounds some of the some of the
results some of the claims are they're
unbelievable yeah yeah the cool part of
what it is is that that's because
they're all true yeah and it's that's a
basic will you base our therapy what you
said earlier about skeptical yeah you
can be skeptical about it but you can't
argue with the results
that's you can argue with why you got
them that's the bottom line a so I
wanted to finish off I know that there
will be some healthcare practitioners
and also some soft tissue workers
chiropractors or the physiotherapists
and other people who work with people
close to them on a daily basis a lot of
my co-hosts on this are in the medical
profession as well friend we had a
really interesting discussion when you
laid me down on a bed that had crystals
underneath it and yeah I just wanted you
to try and retell we try and retell one
of the stories that you had to do with
the way that people who are practicing
on patients can sometimes have a they
can have a bad time do - yeah due to the
way that the patients are failing yeah I
just wanted to hear that I was
fascinated by that sure I mean you walk
into a room somebody walks into a room
they're really angry you can feel it you
know they sometimes it's like that like
a friend walks on earth or wife or
girlfriend what walks in the room you
did something wrong you feel it so
energy is transferred
energy is transferred and collected and
there's like there just there's so much
science to prove that's true to even
ignore to say that it doesn't is it's
not right anymore
um and so what happens is the body
collects and holds on to the energy from
people and so what we've done is we we
use a lot of techniques but we just
don't say two things they say crystals
on the table I showed you that that's a
little trade secret we use quartz
crystals organized around the table in a
very specific fashion to create a net
result and one of them is decompression
and decompression and what causes
compression is trauma or torque same
thing so what we do is as we started
putting the crystals on the table as a
client this treatment would speed up by
twice and the practitioners could do
three to five times more work without
feeling the fatigue they would normally
feel and is basically again it's just
using something it doesn't sound like
it's credible so we just don't make a
big deal of it we just do it because it
works that's interesting I think there's
definitely an implication no matter
whether you think that the solution is
quartz crystals on a bed or mindfulness
practice or sitting with your thoughts
or yoga or anything I think that there
is definitely an implication for
healthcare professionals that by one
system or another whether it's socially
psychologically as you're discussing the
mechanism that this particular energy
works on I do think that it is um it's
an important an important thing for them
to keep in mind that they are dealing
with people that are sick and unwell all
that yeah absolutely and there's a lot
of stuff that goes along with that I
mean I used to get sick going home and I
was like I didn't put hands on people
until just a little under ten years ago
and and I I did wasn't prepared for what
would happen when you have when you're
working with a sick and and frustrated
people that have through horrible abuses
and sexual abuse and physical abuse and
all kinds of injuries and stuff like
that that stuff is it's pretty thick and
pretty heavy and having a mechanism to
clear it is really important it's your
practitioner and you don't have a daily
routine or routine to clear that stuff
eventually it adds up and what we're
doing is we still see practitioners who
are
in 20 25 30 years working with people
like that we're cleaning up that mess
now it's best that people if you don't
have a routine to learn one and a lot of
stuff that we use crisps over the next
between now and q1 next year we'll be
publishing a lot of it I was literally
just I was literally just about to say
so obviously you're talking about the
the home therapy that you'd be doing
which is typically typically more for
patients for practice for practitioners
will there be any resources that they
will be able to tap into which will
assist them yeah a couple things again
if it's if it works at home it usually
works in there practitioner environments
so so yeah how we organize crystals
around the table and different effects
including decompression charging the
body energized for both male and female
there's also for the first time ever in
the history of Garage we're going to be
doing outward certification starting in
about three months and we're going to be
training our training torque mechanics
and our intention is to use torque
mechanics work really well with
chiropractic offices because the body
often the spine when it's been torque
for a long time it gets on torque it
needs to be needs to be adjusted and so
we're gonna be a certifying torque
mechanics out because the one thing that
we have is we have people from all over
the world trying to get it the one thing
that we're short on is people to deliver
care so we're gonna take the care on the
road and instead of just trying to build
a bunch of game with Rogers we're just
gonna start training people how that how
to help people as quick as we can
you've mentioned that before is that
going to be franchising or a licensing
or how's that gonna work yeah so the
general mode out general mode is that
people that are registered to arc
mechanics will get leads from us because
we have a plethora of leads coming in I
was gonna say and you're not gonna be
sure on lead generation right no no
that's not gonna be a problem as a
matter of fact that's part of the reason
why we took down our website years ago
it's just that you have to you have to
have some sort of control the flow and
now we want to open it up and and give
give people like literally if you're a
chiropractor out there and you want to
do this work you'll be able to do
portions of this work by having to
torque mechanics work with you and what
our chiropractors will tell you is that
they have a 75%
reduction of force and the adjustment
and the adjustment lasts three to five
times longer when you take the torque by
the body Wow
well I mean you know I I think over the
coming the coming weeks and coming
months I'll definitely be posting a lot
more of your stuff I think there'll be a
lot of people that will be interested in
it
can you tell can you tell the listeners
at home there will be some people that I
know that are listening in LA and not
too far from you can they can you tell
them where they can find you first
online and then where the practice is
sure yeah we're in Marina Del Ray Beach
Avenue right down in the heart of Venice
and Marina del Rey you can give us a
human Garage net and if they are coming
off your podcast if they put your name
in the referral bar they're not gonna
get in right away but they're gonna jump
to the head of the line we take care of
our our clients the referrals our media
partners first and their referrals and
then then we go off to everybody else
after that
so they put your name into our wait list
what we'll do is we'll move them to the
to the front of the wait the wait list
that's fantastic thank you I really
appreciate that Gary so if you're
listening at home modern wisdom when you
do your referral or quote Chris
Williamson yourself I want to say as
well Gary I've actually got the guys
behind essential oil coming on soon
essential oil wizardry oh you got Oh dr.
Nick listen here's my favorite dr. nick
is a special human being yeah there are
no there are no whales anywhere in the
world like his we have searched the
entire world and that's why we've
partnered with his natural I know so I
heard him on Ben Greenfield and I really
wanted to get a hold of him after I'd
after I'd listened to him it's another
you know from a similar kind of school
as yourselves it it's the sort of thing
which does sound contrary and it sounds
different but you know bottom line
results results are interesting and I
think it's worthy of further
investigation well the the British
Medical Journal was the first one I
think to report on two things we you
know because we we listen to Al Pathak
but British medicine Journal reported on
Mirza 7/7 clients to use manuka honey
and terminal terminal clients for mrs a
and use manuka honey declare alright and
the other part too is as the other than
the American medical drama they have
lots of references to essential oils
frequency that there's not a bacteria in
the world that is resistant to essential
oils so that's one new consistent you
know you can put in your back pocket
these those are some unbelievable sort
of start so that's the British Medical
Journal talking about manuka honey and
bacterial resistance to aromatherapy
oils right yeah it's it's pretty
incredible they had seven patients who
had lesions they were gonna die from
versa and at this point they got nothing
left you try it whatever so they used
manuka honey all seven of them lived and
there's a whole bunch of things like
that coming just watch over the next
couple of years what we think is what
we've been told and what we think about
how the body works just not that way and
I just encourage people to have an open
mind and just investigate a little bit
more and keep asking the question why I
was going to say do you do you feel like
this is the beginning of the crest of a
wave towards a new direction for
wellness and for the way that the
medical world you know fixing people
absolutely we are on there we're on the
forefront where we are we are breaking
new science new frontiers every single
day here and if we're doing it here
there's other people doing it all over
the world we just don't know about them
yet maybe we're in a better spot we get
a bit more media here but whoever you
are out there if you're actually
changing the world and and doing things
that are going to actually benefit the
world just keep doing it and don't
listen to people well hopefully we'll
have contacted some of them and they'll
have a kindred spirit with yourself on
the other side here on the other side of
the internet so Gary I really appreciate
your time I loved my time when I came
out to come and see I'm hopefully gonna
be back in LA not very soon and I can't
wait to come back and see you again for
sure absolutely it's it's been a blast
thank you much thank you take care bye
bye
[Music]